[Music]
cambridge university's vice chancellor
stephen tupe has announced that he'll be
standing down for his position in
september 2022.
in this announcement he said i take a
great deal of pride in our
accomplishments which were built
together as a collegiate cambridge
community but at the same time the
upheaval of covert has led me to
reassess my own years ahead from a
personal perspective being near my own
family and friends is more important
than ever
so what will his legacy be douglas
murray writes for the spectator's
website this week that his time in the
post has been an unmitigated disaster
to explain douglas joins me now
douglas thank you for coming on today
stephen troop has resigned so what do
you think is really behind it
um well
the vice chancellor of cambridge has
said that he is going to step down early
from his tenure because he wants to
spend more time with his family uh which
may be the case uh it's a rather
famous infamous cop-out phrase normally
certainly in in british politics people
say they want to spend more time with
their families when they know no one
else wants to spend time with them
generally um
but yes so that's his claim uh it's very
unlikely to be true
uh stephen troop's tenure at cambridge
has been marred by a whole set of
controversies
uh
battles within the university and indeed
with the wider culture
that have mattered very much and stephen
tube has been losing these battles one
by one
uh he's brought an enormous amount of
negative attention to cambridge
university uh um most observers have
recognized that his tenure in position
has been absolutely lamentable and uh so
i think it's rather obvious you don't
really need to read between the lines to
come to this conclusion but he's leaving
because he's no good at the job and
everyone
knows and what about china do you think
that uh that has played a role in his
demise
this is very interesting uh the
spectator of course we ran a cover piece
about this uh just a couple of months
ago um about the extraordinary way
in which stephen tupe's
period in cambridge has coincided with
an amazing amount of sucking up to the
authorities in china for funding and
more and our cover piece which exposed
that
uh
was
was not able to be refuted by cambridge
university a few lackluster attempts to
try it
but nobody could deny the facts i mean
they start from the fact that very
shortly after his tenure began at
cambridge university stephen two went
straight to the chinese embassy and had
his photographs taken and talked about
the importance of greater cooperation
between the authorities in china and
educational institutions in the uk such
as his own um cambridge during his
tenure
took significant amounts of funding from
chinese
government linked organizations and
backers and uh there were many many
reports as we laid out in our cover
piece of academics and others who saw
that this was a complete uh um
completely contrary to a university's
interests and that the involvement of
the chinese authorities in cambridge uh
clearly compromised free academic
inquiry it was an extraordinary
misjudgment stephen tube couldn't defend
it and i think it's certainly one of the
reasons why he's going
are you hopeful then that although the
successor has not yet been appointed we
could start to see actually a reversal
when it comes to the university's
approach to dealing with china
i i would certainly hope so
what stephen tupe's tenure at cambridge
uh um
shows is something wider just than the
china question though see what's so
striking about it
is that a vice chancellor of a british
university should be sucking up to the
communist party of china
at the same time as instituting a whole
set of new speech codes himself or
trying to uh within cambridge university
uh
stephen two forever talked uh during his
tenure about uh academic freedom whilst
overseeing the trashing of it as i said
on the spectator online this week uh his
tenure for instance coincided with the
sacking of a young academic called noah
carl from one of cambridge's colleges um
purely because a mob of completely
uninformed students claimed that carl's
research was in some way racist and he
was fired and that was overseen by two
that was a complete uh um
demolition
of the principle of academic freedom uh
whereby mobs cannot simply turn up
outside colleges and demand the firing
of people whose research they don't
understand uh more infamously perhaps
stephen two oversaw and defended
the very ignominious firing of a better
canadian than himself uh professor
jordan peterson
who a few years ago was meant to have
taken up a visiting professorship
that is a non-paying
fellowship at cambridge for a term in
the theology faculty and that invitation
was rescinded by the authorities at
cambridge when it was discovered that at
a meet and greet after an event one of
the thousands of people who jordan
peterson had been photographed uh
standing beside was somebody wearing a
t-shirt that said i'm a proud
islamophobe and for standing beside
somebody with a t-shirt that's
controversial
uh stephen tupe uh said yes it's correct
that this man should john peterson uh
should have his offer of a visiting
fellowship removed so
there were very strange rules that were
going on in his time uh perhaps it might
also be said uh that he oversaw uh other
types of controversy in cambridge um
without being able to manage them either
uh um there are quite a lot that i list
in the spectator online um that show
that actually stephen tube in his tenure
at cambridge had very little
understanding of academic freedom which
is perhaps why he found the chinese
authorities so um
amenable
now we've covered some of the issues
during troops reign in that position but
i suppose the big question as to where
this will mark a change in direction
uh is who will be his successor do we
have any idea there
uh no we don't yet my suspicion will be
that toop and the two pipes or two pians
uh will try to install somebody toop
like
to succeed him perhaps somebody's
learned from his errors
um
but i would hope that cambridge
university which is one of the jewels in
the crown not just of british
intellectual life
but the intellectual life of the world
um could do rather better than that um
there are a few people that worked
actually quite recently when i wrote
about
stephen tupe in the telegraph
a small band of his loyalists wrote
a factually inaccurate uh riposte to my
piece um claiming things that weren't
true and i would imagine that that small
band of loyalists would try to find
somebody like him to be his replacement
but there would be many many uh people
in fact almost anybody who'd be better
in the position than he was and there
are quite a lot of reasons for that and
there's one other which perhaps i should
lay out which is that
a tupe in his time consistently oversaw
and led efforts to um crack down on free
speech within cambridge university
there was the infamous case last
december when he uh tried to push
through
a whole set of rules that included the
demand that all professors and faculty
and students uh would have to respect
the opinions of others and a number of
sharp-eyed academics at cambridge which
there are no small number of notice that
the demand to respect somebody else's
opinion is is quite wrong there's no
reason why a totally fallacious opinion
for instance should be respected and
they changed the wording to tolerate
other opinions which may seem like a
small semantic difference but it's a
whole world of difference when you're
discussing and debating difficult issues
for instance which is quite quite
exactly what uh people at university
should be doing so to lost that vote he
subsequently tried to push through an
even more uh um
authoritarian basically set of demands
uh he published
the university published a whole set of
new rules which included rules on the
reporting of microaggressions uh
microaggressions as i often say are
things so small that they almost
certainly don't even exist in a lot of
cases but the reporting of
microaggressions at the university was
encouraged people encouraged to for
instance
report anonymously on other students or
faculty who are claimed to have made a
or committed a microaggression
and an example of a microaggression was
the raising of an eyebrow whilst any
member of any minority group was
speaking uh as i said at the time a a a
cambridge where you couldn't raise an
eyebrow is under cambridge that many of
us would recognize um but uh this this
was published and uh
i and others uh said this is uh not
worthy of an institution of cambridge's
stature to to to push through such
ridiculous uh demands and uh stephen
tupe and his loyalists at the time
pretended uh firstly that the the thing
that they had published didn't say what
it said
then two admitted he hadn't read it
before he published it and i think then
claimed that the dog had eaten his
website or something like that
uh he used every excuse in the box and
again um this this culture he tried to
push through has to be reversed it has
to be chucked out there can be no truck
with this it's not it's not um a serious
uh set of demands or claims that
are fit for a serious institution so uh
we just have to hope that uh the
institution is taken back into the hands
of uh grown-ups
rather than the people fighting a sort
of imported woe karate culture war and
trying to impose it on one of the jewels
in the crown of world education but as i
say in in my piece of the spectator
website this week
the reason why i object to it is to
steal a line from the great evelyn war
is because
watching
steven tupe in charge of cambridge
university
was like uh watching a delicate valuable
severe vars in the hands of a chimpanzee
um
the man careered around with this
precious thing
and didn't seem to mind if he smashed
the whole thing uh he seemed to have no
idea of the value of the thing that was
in his hands uh seemed to think it was a
sort of version of a rather bland
canadian bar organization but without
the thrills and without the pay it has
to be said um so hopefully the
university will be wrestled back
by some of the many many brilliant men
and women who work there and it should
be
for the many brilliant students who
study there and should expect much
better than they got in the era of tube
and just finally douglas the government
has been looking at things like a
freedom of speech bill uh which could
see uh when it comes to campuses fines
or sanctions for those who are in breach
of it do you think that could be a
useful tool or is that the wrong
approach
it could be i'm slightly skeptical about
it i'm rather skeptical of the concept
of the free speech tsar and other such
things i mean whoever it is would have
to be um purer than
mother teresa or gandhi or or anyone
else
i don't think such a person will be able
to be found or agreed upon um so i am
slightly skeptical of the government's
actual proposals whilst um
lording the the the principles behind
them um it just it just has to be
stressed that th that universities must
be places
for free inquiry at the very highest
level uh they must be places of robust
debate and discussion and discovery uh
and they should not be
able to be treated like the sort of
nursery gardens that they have been
in recent uh years
so i very much hope that the situation
does change at cambridge but there's one
final point i might make on this which
is that it's very important i think for
people to realize one lesson that should
be taken from all of this
uh occasionally people have said why are
you so invested in in this issue of
cambridge university's vice chancellor
and it isn't just as i say because it
seems to me to matter very much that our
institutions aren't taken over by people
who are unworthy and unfit for them
but also because it's very important
that people realize that when you get
sort of whitmer pool like bureaucrats
like
tube it's very important that people
realize that they largely succeed
because they parrot and then get ahead
of the particular dogmas of the era and
then punish people who aren't parroting
exactly the dogmas and people like to uh
um
rise up in public life and take over
institution after institution because
they keep ahead of that lamentable curve
and they think that there's only
something to gain uh from doing so and
for them in the short term that might be
correct they collect
salaries of hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of pounds a year they benefit
very nicely from it but what i suggest
is that people see that as well as
people being able to benefit from
getting ahead of this i think lamentable
curve there are also dangers from doing
so and there are um punishments indeed
for doing so i think that that toop
should be seen to be immoral
a moral story there it's one of the
things that happens
when you try to make people who are
smarter than you
uh follow through on dumb ideas and dumb
dogmas
one of the things that can happen from
that is that people will rebel you will
actually be chucked out or effectively
be forced to leave your job there is a
downside to being too woke as well as an
upside
[Music]
you